[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Hey, Averi.
AVERI KITSCH: Hey, Grant.
What's up?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Hey,
you would not guess this.
Our critter watch app--
the traffic has been exploding
in the last few months
with all the viewers checking
out our cute animals.
And our product manager, Martin?
He's requested we introduce
some realtime functionality
in our Cloud Run web app.
Specifically, we're looking
to add realtime chat.
AVERI KITSCH: Wow, that
sounds really cool.
GRANT TIMMERMAN:
However, I'm not sure
where to start from the
technical side of things.
I mean, there's HTTP Push, gRBC,
Websockets, server-sent events,
polling, et cetera.
AVERI KITSCH: Oh, I can help.
Let's walk through our options.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it comes to realtime
communication with services,
there are a couple options--
server-sent events,
Websockets, and gRPC.
Server-sent events
use the HTTP protocol
to create a persistent,
one-directional connection
to send data from the
server to the client.
Server-sent events are great
for apps where you don't need
to send any data to the server.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh,
that sounds really good,
especially for like a
Twitter-style news feed,
or maybe like a realtime
dashboard of stock quotes.
But in this case,
we need a chat app
to have bidirectional
communication.
What are the other options?
AVERI KITSCH: Well,
Cloud Run also
supports Websockets,
which allows
us to open a two-directional
connection between the client
and server.
Both the client and server
can trigger communication
with one another, and both can
send messages at the same time.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh,
that sounds amazing.
AVERI KITSCH: But
wait, there is more.
You also mentioned gRPC,
which can also enable
bidirectional communication.
But it uses HTTP/2 protocol
and a remote procedure call
framework.
Though there is a web proxy for
browser-server communication,
gRPC is mostly used
for communication
between backend services.
So in this case, for
a two-way chat app,
I would recommend Websockets.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: OK, that
all sounds really clear.
Thanks.
So let's go and
look at the code.
So it looks like in
Martin's chat app,
we use Websockets
using Socket.IO.
So how does this work?
AVERI KITSCH: Socket.IO is a
nice wrapper for Websockets
and provides some
additional features.
And just like using the
Websocket API directly,
we will install and initialize
Socket.IO on both the client
and the server.
The server will listen for
the connection event, which
allows us to access the socket
instance on both the client
and server.
The socket instance can emit
and listen for messages.
GRANT TIMMERMAN:
All right, cool.
So how do I then deploy
this on Cloud Run?
AVERI KITSCH: One of the
great parts about Websockets
is it comes out of the
box with Cloud Run.
I can deploy this straight from
my terminal using gcloud, which
can also handle containerizing
the application by specifying
my source directory.
Now that it's deployed,
let's test it out
by logging into a chat room.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh, awesome.
And it looks like Martin's
already in the app.
Oh, however, there
seems to be an issue.
Messages are disappearing
between sessions.
Do you know how to
fix that, Averi?
AVERI KITSCH: I think I
know what the problem is.
Cloud Run automatically scales
container instances and load
balances every request between
the available instances.
Therefore, your client
may be connecting
to a different
container instance,
and we haven't setup any way
to share or store the data.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: So I guess
we need to save the chat
messages to a database?
AVERI KITSCH: Well, a
database doesn't quite
solve this problem,
because you need to poll
the database for updates.
But we can avoid
polling altogether
by using a Publisher/Subscriber
broker like Redis.
Container instances can
publish to a specific channel,
as well as subscribe
for push updates.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: OK, so
yeah, that sounds good.
How then do we add that?
AVERI KITSCH: First, we'll go
create a Redis instance for us
to use via Cloud Memorystore.
Our Redis instance lives
in a virtual private cloud,
which means it's not accessible
from the outside internet.
So I'll also have to go
create a serverless VPC access
connector, so our
Cloud Run service can
connect to our Redis instance.
When we redeploy, we'll need
our Redis IP and the name
of our serverless
VPC access connector.
Can you update the app
to subscribe and publish
to the Redis channels?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Well, using
Socket.IO, all I had to do
was update it to use
the Redis adapter.
And it handles broadcasting
events to all clients,
regardless of what
container instances
they are connected to.
We can connect to
the Redis instance
with the IP and port
environment variables
when deploying our
Cloud Run service.
AVERI KITSCH: Let's
deploy our changes
and specify our new
Redis environment
variable and the VPC connector.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh, it works.
That was easy.
AVERI KITSCH: I'm so
glad we got it working.
GRANT TIMMERMAN:
I'm so glad, too.
And now I know the difference
between server-side events,
Websockets, and gRPC.
It's so easy to use
Websockets with Cloud Run
to add realtime chat
to Martin's app.
AVERI KITSCH: And don't forget,
with Websockets and Redis,
we're able to store
and coordinate
our data with thousands of users
across all of our container
instances.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Well,
thanks so much, Averi.
I'm sure Martin
will be very happy.
Oh, it looks like I have a
lot of messages to reply to.
Yeah, let me get to that.
AVERI KITSCH: Awesome.
See you next time.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]